bien plus quand vous allez pas chez
drucker je crois que cette interview
vous fera plaisir
dick rivers est ce qu'on peut dire que
vous êtes le dernier des grands rockers
oui vos textes sont vraiment des bijoux
d'humour d'écriture c'est quoi votre
secret bien m'entourer way savoir
m'entourer de gens qui écrivent
merveilleusement bien pour mettre leur
talent au service de ma voix somptueuse
vous êtes sans doute l'un des meilleurs
chanteurs de votre génération des
chanteurs comme vous il y en a pas
beaucoup qui peuvent lui succéder je
vois pas de sucre 1 heure je pense qu'on
écoutera ma musique encore dans des
centaines d'années vous avez effectué un
parcours sans faute dit qu'une carrière
impeccable qu'est ce que vous pourriez
faire d'encore plus fort aujourd'hui a
peut-être un film sur ma vie où je
jouerai mon propre
vous avez conscience de ce charisme
animal qui émane de bouddhique
oui d'ailleurs ça me pose souvent des
problèmes parce que les amis notamment
avec les animaux mais des voeux attentes
je me promène dans la rue je vois tous
ces gens se ruaient vers moi surtout si
merveilleuse jeunes se tiennent résiste
vous êtes vous est incroyablement sexy
c'est vrai comment vous résister aux
sollicitations féminine dick
je mets un slip en béton pas plus de 40
ans de carrière des concerts à guichet
fermé une centaine de disques d'or de
victoires de la musique c'est mérité
ah oui oui et puis je trouve quelque
part il ya certain que j'aurais dû
mériter par exemple les les musiques
wars d'énergie je n'ai pas eu et il y a
un truc est marrant c'est par choix vous
avez refusé de faire une grande carrière
internationale
voilà ma fille ouais c'est ça toulon et
nice n'ont pas de nice de la france
adore la france donc j'ai jamais libre
voulu aller plus loin que le québec prix
que j'adore honnêtement sans vous
l'industrie du disque en france seraient
dans la merde on avait fait ce que me
dit hemayma maison du tourisme
heureusement que tu es là parce que
c'est pas avec les autres artistes que
on arrivait à faire notre beurre parce
que vous pensez qu'on vous mérite
vraiment ce soir
écoutez je me suis tapé pour venir mais
je me suis dit bon baffier sympathique
je le connais puis bon thierry ardisson
unis soit comme moi donc c'est un peu un
pays
merci d'être là en tous les cas merci